ces sportifs jouent avec les lois de la
pesanteur le tumbling discipline au
programme des jo de 1932 à los angeles
est un dérivé de la gymnastique
l'objectif les tome leur doivent
enchaîner huit acrobaties consécutive
sur une piste de 25 mètres de long pour
séduire les juges et on déplace en
arrière ça monte très haut ça voilà
entre autres essences il ya des
rotations en vrille ou en salle aux
nuits à une recherche du prise de
vitesse
le support est beaucoup plus élastique
donc une amplitude plus grande donc
entre la gym et
et de tom nous la différence je dirais
c'est le temps d'accompagner les plus
grands comme nous parce qu'on mange
beaucoup plus haut à la différence de la
gym seuls les contacts avec les pieds et
avec les mains sont autorisés avec la
vitesse les chômeurs doivent maîtriser
leurs figures pour ne pas se blesser
il faut faire surtout attention j'ai eu
d un peu de problèmes aux articulations
mais quand
quant aux échanges après ça va quand on
voit comme ça tout le monde pense que
c'est une discipline qui est très
dangereuse mais je vous dis si elle est
faite avec précaution ça veut dire que
dire aux enfants les dangers
les risques ne pas faire n'importe quoi
des relais de l'entraîneur ça c'est
important
après l'accident peut arriver le
département des yvelines compte 99
licenciés répartis dans trois clubs
affiliés à la fédération française de
gymnastique
ce chiffre représente près de dix pour
sonder tumblr présents dans l'hexagone